yes that's her okay let's follow her one
migrant worker dies every week in
Lebanon and told me that he is a cemetry
I will kill you in the night include a
rarely seen on camera
we followed the escape of just one
worker fleeing for her life the Kafala
system is modern day slavery there's no
two ways about it it looks like such an
ordinary moment but it's far from that
it's the story of an escape from slavery
and you're watching it as it's happening
sera 26 from Ghana is stuck in Lebanon
she's allowed us to capture this moment
as she slips away from abusive families
she's been working for well we're just
approaching Beirut now in the first
stage of her escape is almost complete
in a suburb she's met by another
Ghanaian woman who escaped a similar
ordeal a few months ago our introduction
is brief loss and filmed discreetly how
you do okay cameras here will rouse
suspicion how you feel I came to live on
to work and get money I went with some
woman the one who bring me in late on
Thursday when I came they received me
good with the husband they were good to
me only one week they change if you do
any mistakes you use her shoes to be
beating so there the lashes was too much
for me I ran I'm sorry so they hit you
with shoes yes if she is coming to wake
you up she use her shoes to wake me up
so I decided to run I ran from the house
Sarah is not her real name we've changed
it at her request to protect her from
reprisals she's a victim of a system
called Kaif Allah Arabic for sponsorship
migrants encouraged to the Middle East
for work but with no rights at all their
agents control their lives and their
destiny so you managed to to escape from
that first family yes so I went to
another different family from the my
office who bring you they give me some
woman I went there to wait there were
sexual harassment is too much one of my
Madam's
brother you want to sleep with me he
told me that this is $20 take and let me
spend my night with you I said no I
didn't came here because of sex and
money the next day he came I was in the
bathroom scribal he came with naked he
didn't wear anything he would knife
and do me like this and tell me do you
know this I said knife so he put it on
my neck and told me that if you don't
know and you tell my and my sister I
will show you here is asymmetry I will
kill you in the night and crow you dead
no one would know that is me so I was
quiet and listen to me told me from
today going everyday I have to suck your
breasts I have to do this I have to do
this I don't even want to remember
because what this guy did to me it was
very painful it was very painful
I'm so sorry
the challenges in the dangers ahead are
still huge
she has no papers and no money I don't
have the passport no who has the
passport is with my agent I don't have
the password the agent only she collect
money from me
she collect my money she beats me and
collect my money from my hand this is
not an isolated case
far from it there are a quarter of a
million migrant domestic workers in
Lebanon all under this system the Kafala
system is modern day slavery there's no
two ways about it
human rights groups have lobbied
politicians for years but nothing has
changed unfortunately most people here
and still don't understand the inherent
racism of the Kafala system they think
that the abuse that we see day in and
day out is the result of a few bad
employers rather than a system that is
built on the exploitation and
subjugation of these women and it's it's
widespread it really is I mean people
think that they have a right to have a
migrant domestic worker live in their
homes 24/7
we couldn't find to her room not have
her passport with her these are all
things that because of decades of
practice have just become completely
normalized
and this goes beyond domestic workers
outside African embassies across the
city migrants are waiting for their
nations help at the Sudanese embassy
they are men Lebanon's economy is
collapsing and so these laborers have
literally been dumped by their employers
they take us as slaves if I use myself
they take me as a slave there are many
people who is Iranian DSL to come they
shouldn't come because this journey is
doing that is very very serious case
they shouldn't come the Lebanese
government has in the past acknowledged
that the system needs reforms but
they've yet to be implemented our
request for an interview have not been
met the charity who helped Sarah escape
will now work with Ghana's embassy to
try to get her and so many others like
her home mark stone Sky News in Lebanon